Speaker 1: Well, it has been a very consequential
24 hours for Donald Trump, for the Justice
Department, for the January 6th Committee.
We have so many pieces of breaking news to
talk about, and I want to start first and
foremost with a federal judge's opinion that
Donald Trump likely committed multiple felonies
in trying to overturn the results of the 2020
election.
Now we're going to talk about what this means
and what it doesn't mean.
And many of you rightly writing to me correctly,
writing to me and saying, David, wait, a judge
determines whether Trump is guilty.
Doesn't a jury do that?
This is not a determination of criminality
for the purposes of punishment.
Donald Trump has not been charged.
The context here is evidence.
And does there appear to be a legitimate reason
to turn over certain records on the basis
that it seems reasonable that Donald Trump
committed crimes and thus the evidence is
legitimate to be looked at by investigators?
And we're going to talk about that, and we
have some very specific comments about this
from legal experts.
Let's start with the New York Times article.
Federal judge finds Trump most likely committed
crimes over the 2020 election, the judge wrote
in a civil case the illegality of the plan
was obvious.
Separately, the January six panel voted to
recommend contempt of Congress charges for
two former Trump aides.
This article is worth reading in its entirety.
The important points here.
A federal judge ruled yesterday that Trump
and a lawyer who advised him on how to overturn
the 2020 election most likely had committed
felonies, including obstructing the work of
Congress and conspiring to defraud the United
States.
The judge's comments on the civil case of
the lawyer, John Eastman, marked a significant
breakthrough for the House Committee investigating
the riots.
The committee is weighing making a criminal
referral to the Justice Department had used
a filing in the case to lay out the crimes
it believed Trump might have committed.
Importantly, Trump has not been charged with
any crime.
The judge's ruling has no immediate, practical
legal effect on him, but it ratifies the committee's
argument that Trump's efforts to block Congress
from certifying Biden's win could well rise
to the level of a criminal conspiracy.
This is, we can't let this be normalized.
It is outrageous that this is what is going
on.
Judge David Carter wrote quote the illegality
of the plan was obvious.
Our nation was founded on the peaceful transition
of power epitomized by George Washington,
laying down his sword to make way for democratic
elections.
Ignoring this history, President Trump vigorously
campaigned for the vice president to single
handedly determine the results of the 2020
election.
So what are our questions here?
Well, the first question is, does this finally
give the Attorney General, Merrick Garland,
a way to move forward with the criminal charges?
And the answer is it probably does, but he
probably won't.
Now what's really important to understand
here is what does this mean?
This is not a judge ruling that a crime was
committed.
That's for a jury to do if charges are brought.
But I asked former FBI special agent who's
now a lawyer, Asuran Gupta.
She teaches at Yale Law School.
I asked her about this on Twitter, and she
explained very clearly.
Quote The judge's opinion is in itself evidence
of a crime.
It's an evaluation of some of the evidence,
which is the grand jury's job, I'd say.
At most, it suggests that a grand jury would
be able to independently find probable cause
to charge.
But the problem is proving it beyond a reasonable
doubt to a jury.
Asia went on to add the judge may have just
been stating what was obvious from the evidence,
but no doubt it's a major flag that this had
better be an active Department of Justice
investigation.
Dereliction of duty if it is not.
So this is the main point, and we've been
talking about this for some time.
I don't think anybody is arguing.
Let me put it a different way.
Due process holds that one is innocent until
proven guilty and due process holds that we
can't say someone should be punished for a
crime until they've been found guilty of a
crime.
And right now, Donald Trump has not even been
charged.
So we're, you know, the right loves to say
they're all about law and order, but they
will immediately suspend due process when
they want someone quote locked up.
Think Hillary Clinton?
We're not going to do that.
We're going to stick to due process.
But what is abundantly clear at this point
is we have endless opinions, including now
from a federal judge, that it's at least quite
plausible that felonies have been committed.
And so what does that mean?
It doesn't mean you throw someone in jail
before getting a guilty verdict.
But it does mean there should be an active
investigation and Asuran Raghubar is completely
correct about that.
So this ruling affects a very specific part
of the process of investigation.
It relates to a civil case.
It's not time for jail.
We're not saying lock anybody up.
It's the right that loves to do that by skipping
due process.
But what we are saying is if there's no investigation
going on right now, it raises some major major
questions that we need to have answered.
And unfortunately, what we saw in Manhattan
is very similar to this.
Remember that Mark Pomerantz and another prosecutor
investigating Trump criminally in Manhattan
resigned.
And initially, many on the right were saying
they resigned because they knew that it was
all bogus and there was nothing to investigate.
No, we speculated, and it's since been confirmed.
They resigned because they actually thought,
Wow, Trump did commit crimes, and it doesn't
seem there's any interest in actually charging
him.
And so our work is essentially being done
for nothing.
We found evidence of criminality.
Nobody's interested in charging the guy I'm
out of here.
That's what happened.
So we're seeing the same story.
Federal judge, civil case, Manhattan investigators,
everybody coming to the conclusion felonies
were probably committed here.
Will he be charged?
I'm not.
I'm not particularly optimistic.